Brand power.
Helping you buy better.
>> CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FACE'S FIRST SANCTUARY STATE
IN JANUARY.
LAW PROHIBITS POLICE FROM
DETAINING CRIMINAL ALIENS.
WITH THOUSANDS LIVING IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY ON SKID ROW
HYGIENE IS ALWAYS AN ISSUE.
WITH OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS A
IT'S ALWAYS A NECESSITY.
>> JUST BEFORE MIDNIGHT
ANDERSON WAS DRIVING
SEMI-TRUCK ON INTERSTATE 70.
THE MAN CHARGED WITH
ANDERSON'S DEATH IS IVAN, HE
AS UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
OUT ON BOND WANTED BY ICE.
>> Tucker: THE GOLDEN STATE
HAS LOST ITS GLOW,
OBVIOUSLY.
CALIFORNIA NOW HAS MORE
POVERTY THAN ANY STATE.
HOMELESSNESS IS COMPLETELY
OUT OF CONTROL.
STATE OFFICIALS ARE STILL
FOCUSED ON PRESENTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
DEPORTATION RATHER THAN
THINK PROBLEMS THE STATE
FACES.
SAD PICTURE.
ONE MAN WHO SEES IT CLEARLY
HAS BEEN THERE A LONG TIME
ACTOR MODEL FABIO.
FABIO JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, FABIO, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> TUCKER, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I READ ABOUT
CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY.
HERE ARE TWO HEADLINES.
TELL ME IF THEY SUM UP WHAT
IT'S LIKE NOW.
THIS IS FROM THE OTHER DAY.
ORANGE COUNTY HOMELESS CAMP
CLEAN UP 400 TONS OF DEBRIS.
14,000 NEEDLES, 5,000 POUNDS
OF HUMAN WASTE.
HERE'S THE SECOND.
CALIFORNIA LOWERS THE
PENALTY FOR KNOWINGLY EXPOSE
GHTSDZ SOMEONE TO H.I.V.
IT SOUNDS CHAOTIC AND DIRTY.
IS THAT YOUR EXPERIENCE?
>> YEAH, WELL, LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING RIGHT NOW
ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
IT LOOKED LIKE THE WILD,
WILD WEST.
DON'T LOOK FARTHER THAN THE
LEADERS OF CALIFORNIA JERRY
BROWN, LEVY, THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND.
YOU KNOW, JERRY BROWN,
PROPOSITION 47, 57, 109
TOTALLY THE SIDE OF THE
CRIMINALS.
ON THE CRIMINAL SIDE.
TURN BACK ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND YOU KNOW, THE LEADERS OF
CALIFORNIA, THEY ACTING
CRIMINALS.
THEY ARE ACTING LIKE
SO WHAT DO YOU EXPECT THE
REST OF THE PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DO?
THEN HAVE YOU THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND WHO TOTALLY TELL ALL
THE CRIMINAL TO RUN AWAY
BECAUSE ICE IS COMING OVER.
SO, INSTEAD TO DO ARREST,
THEY ONLY ARREST ABOUT 120,
130 PEOPLE.
THEN YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, THE
HOMELESS, THE HOMELESS, IF
YOU LOOK -- IF YOU GO
DOWNTOWN, LOS ANGELES, I'M
TELLING YOU, TUCKER, I HAVE
BEEN AROUND THE WORLD.
I REMEMBER 30 YEARS AGO IN
AFRICA.
AFRICA DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THAT.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
NOT EVEN THIRD WORLD COUNTRY
30 YEARS AGO LOOK LIKE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
LIKE DOWNTOWN.
YOU GO DOWN TO THE LIBRARY,
IT'S LIKE SODOM AND
GOMORRAH.
SEX, DRUGS, AND ROCK AND
ROLL.
>> Tucker: IN A LIBRARY?
>> IN THE LIBRARY.
I MEAN, YOU SHOULD DO A
TOTAL SEEING YOU MEANT ON
THE LIBRARY.
A PUBLIC LIBRARY DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES AND I'M TELLING
YOU, IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S LIKE SODOM AND
GOMORRAH.
>> Tucker: ONLY CALIFORNIAN
LIBRARIANS WOULD PUT UP WITH
THAT.
WHEN DID YOU GET TO
CALIFORNIA?
WHEN DID YOU MOVE THERE.
>> IN 1992.
>> Tucker: '92?
>> NOW I GO BACK AND FORTH
BECAUSE I LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
BECAUSE I'M TELLING YOU,
IT'S LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
LEADERS, TOTALLY DESTROYED
THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THE MAJORITY CALIFORNIA
IS BROKEN.
YOU HAVE A FEW WEALTHY
PEOPLE, ABOUT 5700 PEOPLE
PAY ALMOST 37% EXACTLY OF
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA INCOME
TAX.
>> Tucker: THAT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> CALIFORNIA IS BROKE U.
>> Tucker: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
ON TOP OF THAT, COMPANY
EVERY SINGLE COMPANY IS
RUNNING AWAY BECAUSE OF TAX
REASON AND INCLUDING THE
MOVIE INDUSTRY.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE THEY
ARE.
>> EVERY SINGLE MOVIE
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
BE THERE SOON.
WE WILL BRING THE SHOW TO